less co2 from bands MEP is adopted the
report to decrease the co2 emission
limit for new light commercial vehicles
the aim is to reduce co2 emissions from
203 g/km to 175 grams per kilometer
after 2017 and 147 g/km by 2020 but
first on these proposals are not going
far enough we wanted against because
it's too weak the purpose of legislation
is to create drive for more
environmental innovation not a piece of
paper that everybody can fulfill without
any effort really a step closer to safer
products negotiations are to start soon
with a 28 member states on you Product
Safety and market surveillance rules for
instance all products sold and you will
have a label saying where they were made
and there could be an EU safety tested
label to show that a good has been
declared safe by national authorities
guilty species at the Q&A session with
mep scientists presented the latest IPCC
report on climate change the UN climate
panel says it is extremely likely that
humans are the dominant cause of global
warming since the 1950s after 2081 the
sea level could rise between 26 and 82
centimeters nobody can be a hundred
percent certain nobody can foresee the
future but it could be that we've got
like an express train heading straight
towards us and so in my view we should
be sensible to be taking precautions to
say it's not happening and then we hit
by the train that's a catastrophe for
the whole planet